it's now been 15 days since a group of
young boys in Thailand along with their
soccer coach have been trapped by
floodwaters inside a cave heavy rains
are expected to hit the area this
weekend which could make any sort of
rescue attempt nearly impossible Ben
Tracy is outside the cave near Chiang
Rai Ben good morning good morning those
heavy rains would make the flooding
inside the worse and could make any sort
of rescue attempt nearly impossible so
officials here have been debating
whether or not they should quickly try
to attempt one even though that would be
incredibly risky rescuers say the boys
are still too weak and need to learn
more about the diving equipment they
would use to escape the flooded cave
system we tried to set the pen the head
of the rescue mission says they will try
to wait until there is minimal risk to
the boys lives but the air inside the
cave is now a growing concern oxygen
levels have dropped to an alarming 15
percent so crews have rushed to install
a three mile long oxygen tube and have
delivered more tanks to the boys
location they have drained nearly 35
million gallons of water from the cave
it's unclear how much further the water
level needs to drop so the boys could
safely escape without having to swim
under water it would be an extremely
dangerous journey that already claimed
the life of a former Thai Navy SEAL who
passed out underwater Friday inside the
cave
another option to rescue the boys is
drilling a hole into the mountain but
that could take weeks or months the
trapped soccer players have now written
letters to their families delivered out
of the cave by divers in them the kids
right mom and dad don't worry about me
I am fine we want to eat many foods and
go straight home teacher please don't
give us too much homework I love you mom
and dad don't worry we are safe are you
worried about your friends in the cave
yes 15 year-old Gong Pope is on the same
soccer team as the trap boys he was
supposed to go to the cave that day but
his parents needed his motorbike so he
went home instead I I imagine you feel
very relieved not to be in there I also
imagine you feel very bad for your
friends
he says I feel sad and like I abandoned
them and should have stopped them from
going in the cake what would you like to
say to your friends your teammates that
are inside the cave he says please come
out and play soccer with me again now
just in the past few hours we have seen
them clear this street behind us here
that leads up to the cave they've also
put up this green barrier we're not
exactly sure what they're doing but
they're clearly planning to do something
Erol all right Ben Tracy watching
everything closely there in Thailand
thank you you know the coach wrote a
letter to the parents apologizing for
bringing the kids in some of the parents
wrote back saying don't blame yourself
for this you can just imagine the
emotional rollercoaster for everyone
that's involved wonderful for the
parents to get those letters but at the
same time just heartbreaking that you
know with your kids down there and
there's nothing you can do it's not over
yet the one thing that's giving me hope
is seeing the pictures of them smiling
when those first videos came out just
where my parents need that - yes